hello people of YouTube what's up guys
is prestige I'm back in it's been a
while whoa some lag there it's been a
while I know I know I apologize but I
was just kind of taken the Christmas
winter holiday break off to just relax
didn't do any YouTube stuff so I
apologize if you guys were missing
missing content and yeah but I'm back
and I'm gonna be posting vids more and
it's going to be all cool probably a
bunch more vids with that a group that i
was posting with before i got one battle
dome that i actually i got the footage
before break and I thought I'd uploaded
it but I didn't so they look for that on
the way maybe this weekend hopefully
I'll get this video out the day I record
it and hopefully that'll be good be a
CCS so that's yeah so also update on the
ftp thing right now i'm using ftp and
you're going to see in a second how much
i'm using FP FTB a little little
explosion can happen out there but it
sure give me some time to talk but yeah
the ftp thing is done i updated FTB for
those of you dude i don't know i'm i
have a two episodes out in a series of
feed the beasts i I'm gonna look away
just because I look halfway I'm getting
radiation and I updated feed the beast
and i lost my saves and then I just look
at all the stuff knife TV and like oh
maybe I'll do a new server and I'm like
oh I don't want to do it no server so
much work and it's so much to mass all
the complex cities of feed the beast
like seriously you see all that as you
see all that it's up there the explosion
one I want to blow up a jungle since you
normally you blow you blow up a land or
something okay I'm gonna look away
I'm getting to frame those let's go away
over here and normally uh you blow up
some plane to something so I'm like both
blow up a jungle and then I blew up a
jungle and that was that so I do not
know I'm gonna start getting more frames
basically the only reason that you get
friends oh we're just in stop her fect
frames insta perfect frames all right
but yeah so um like my face you'll see
the explosion in the background will go
visit out we won't go in because then we
get horde lag but yeah so basically I
won't be doing ftp i apologize i'll try
to find a new series and yeah i hope i
wasn't rambling too much was kinda just
waiting explosion to go all house that's
a little bit of my timer and now let's
see the damage it does it did you guys
saw I didn't give you a good look
because you guys saw the mountain you
see those trees there oh damn the
bedrock this was a good 1i got like that
i'm not going to go down this and then
all the entities will fall upon me and
it'll suck but let's see if we can get
this side to load up all the entities
are falling regardless crap because i'm
loading the chunks all right um let's
end on a picture of this don't all right
all right all right now let's even to f1
mode f1 there we go alright so this is
that's good shots good choice actually
if everything loaded that would be an
epic shot RBI's I'm getting one frame a
second how we've enjoyed this video if
you did leave a like comment or
subscribe this was literally just an
update videos if you don't do any of
that I'm completely not offended and
yeah also you guys soon peace out over
border